and merrill kelly is your diamondback
starting pitcher outstanding and beating
this padres lineup last saturday at san
diego yeah went six strong innings gave
up only six base hits one run in that
ball game it was a solo homer struck out
four did not walk a batter meryl kelly
as i mentioned a moment ago has just
been hammering away at that strike zone
this season
one walk in his very first start of the
year and hasn't walked a man since
fernando tatis junior the shortstop he
will lead it off followed by
well you were right on the money 94 they
stay away and they strike out to
atheists to open up the ball game
big hurdle cleared right there i'm sure
for merrell and now he'll work to train
christian the centerfielder
moving the ball around nicely
good start for merrill kelly two batters
two strikeouts and now it's manny
machado
that one bounces fair to third
backhanded by andy young and the throw
gets by walker a low throw from andy
machado will stop at second base
so an e5 charged to andy young
machado at second two ounces and here's
the dh tommy fam and the 2-2 to fam is
strike three caulk out him looking
camaro kelly strikes out the side on the
hill is to nelson lament for the padres
nelson has been excellent as you can see
coming off his best start of the year
he's got to be two-strike dominant what
i mean about that 56.6 when he gets to
two strikes he puts him away via the
strikeout
ranks third
in mlb
here's a 3-2
nasty fastball 98 unhittable at the
knees strike three call
to nelson to nelson absolutely perfect
pitch outside corner at the knees 98
with sinking action
after the nelson
fastball
in the air to deep right center
commandant over calling grisham catching
one two three to nelson lumet eric
osborne leads off to san diego second
hosmer holmard last night at dodger
stadium there's a little dunk shot in
front of cole calhoun a lead-off single
for hosmer
will myers now myers 284 and five home
runs
merrill kelly terrific curveball right
there he has struck out for the first
six he's faced
a third two outs
long run for starling martin he's going
to have to hustle and he gets to the
spot so here's fernando tachis jr with
one out of the bases empty
on the ground down the third baseline
it's a fair ball long throw for young
and he overthrows it this time
and another base will be awarded here so
one out and tatis at second base here's
trent grisham and uh slow chopper over
the mound coming into second baseman
could tell marty he will not have an
off-balance throw to make he goes to
third and tati is able to scamper back
after rounding the bag so the second
infield single of the inning for the
padres puts runners on the corners manny
machado gets
put on an intentional walk
so they got him loaded now that'll bring
up tommy pham
in a miss
the sinker up and merrill kelly gets an
enormous out number two that's his fifth
strikeout with an assist from tommy pham
chasing a pitch that was well up out of
the strike zone that time in 92.
now you're right that's a two seam it's
meant to be a sinker down and in like
the pitch he swung over to start the
at-bat but he missed up high with it and
got a good result
so here we go two down for a hosmer who
singled his first time up
vastly improved this year starling
martay in center merrill kelly gold star
he leads them loaded 39 pitches through
the first three for lumet catelyn martin
getting his second look at lumet tonight
struck out looking payoff pitch and
there it is for strike three freezing
marty at strikeout number four for
nelson lament see him raises glove up
throws that perfect pitch
down and in slider so peralta on first
base with two out tristan walker coming
up a low target and a slider swung on it
missed in the dirt strike three fifth
strike out of the night for nelson lumet
looks here into the bottom of the fifth
inning
steven vogt the catcher leading it off
here for arizona on the slider for the
first time lined in the left field on
the
[Music]
oh pounding that glove there with the
bare hand that's lynette saying hey
george and profile
smile off your face man that's a great
match not good
laying it out in left field makes a
spectacular grab
jerks and profar nicely done with a
spectacular grab by jericks and profar
swing and a miss fastball at 98 by him
strikeout number six for danelle
sullivan
two down that bunt based hit is the
second hit of the night for arizona
and gives nick ahmed a chance
he's way out in front of her slider my
gosh it's not even fair that pitch was
not fair back door goes to nelson lament
as we head to the bottom of the sixth
top of the order for the d-backs cole
calhoun
cole calhoun toward the right field
corner and that ball is
gone
cole calhoun well he broke up the lament
no no last weekend in san diego with an
opposite field home run and this time he
pulls it down the right field line
that's his fifth of the year and it's
one nothing diamondbacks just the second
home run given up all year by denelson
lumet and cole calhoun has both of them
and here it is just squeaking over the
fence and into the padre bullpen
first and third here with nobody out to
start the eighth
old calhoun base hit
far show scores to make it two nothing
on that flying into third another rbi
for cole calhoun two-nothing
diamondbacks
calhoun at first ahmed at third
kattel hits it deep to center grisham
backing up near the warning track this
will get ahmed home easily
rbi for cattell marte make it
three-nothing d-backs
hammered toward the left-field corner
this will make it four nothing
starling martay continues his hitting
tear
it's an rbi double
inside the peralta household david belts
that one into right field they're going
to wave starling martay
myers will throw it into second
and it's five nothing diamondbacks